vous remercie beaucoup frédéric est sûre
tout aux uns et aux autres de votre
patience mais avec philippe nous étions
en train de re marier un couple qui
fêtait ses 50 ans de mariage et un
couple qui donne beaucoup pour la cité
le 15e arrondissement en particulier
donc il fallait qu'on soit là je pense
que tu as parlé tout à l'heure du de la
partie terrorisme je voulais vous dire
un mot du dispositif qui est mise en
place par le gouvernement
vous le savez ces sentinelles et puis
dans une moindre mesure cuirasse
sentinelle c'est le dispositif qui est
qui permet effectivement de protéger un
certain nombre de sites sensibles
en complément bien sûr des formes
sécurité etc est donc basé sur une
mobilisation d'environ aujourd'hui 7000
militaires
alors moi je le dis franchement ce qui a
été mis en place au mois de janvier elle
a été très bien faire a été très bien
fait en particulier par la mobilisation
de nos forces armées en particulier
l'armée de terre qui a été capable de
mobiliser 10 mille soldats en un peu
moins d'une semaine
c'est une prouesse faut le reconnaître
notre armée a su dans ce domaine faire
preuve de son efficacité comme elle le
fait tous les jours sur les opérations
sur les théâtres d'opérations
extérieures que ce soit barkan dans la
bande sahélo saharienne
ou encore quand il faut taper en irak et
en syrie avec l'opération chat mâle et
je parle de ce sujet devant pierre qui
que pierre lellouche qui connaît
parfaitement bien le dispositif mis en
place
de 10000 nous sommes en sommes
aujourd'hui un dispositif d'environ 7000
hommes mais qui n'a pas empêché vous
avez pu vous en rendre compte un certain
nombre d'exactions en particulier ce qui
s'est passé sur dans le thalys même si
de fait nous n'étions pas directement
concerné au premier chef mais nous avons
vu la difficulté qu'il y avait à
protéger non seulement des sites
sensibles mais également des moyens de
circulation en particulier tout ce qui
est train et avion se pose donc
aujourd'hui le problème le problème de
notre modèle de protection lié à un
terroriste malheureusement je vais pas
entendu ce qu'a dit lu il ya quelques
instants mais dont on voit bien qu'il
est à la fois extrêmement diffus
extrêmement prégnant dont on sait à peu
près d'où vient la source mais dont on a
encore un peu du mal à suivre à la trace
l'ensemble de celles et ceux qui
fomentent ou qui vont fomenter des actes
criminels sur notre territoire
même si avec nos services de
renseignement dgsi dgse et drm
nous sommes aujourd'hui en capacité d'en
détecter un certain nombre encore
faut-il que tout cela soit mise en ordre
et on voit bien il ya encore beaucoup de
trous dans la raquette
je voulais juste attirer votre attention
sur la difficulté qu'il doit y avoir
déjà appliqué une sorte de doctrine en
matière d'utilisation de notre armée il
ya déjà pas mal de critiques d'ailleurs
qui sont jour sur l'utilisation de
l'armée sur le sol français
est ce sa destination c'est une vraie
question autant on peut comprendre
effectivement que notre armée protège
notre territoire
s'il y avait une agression extérieure en
particulier dans des contres d'andré de
contourner conflits interétatiques
on peut comprendre également que
évidemment notre armée soit projeté
comme elle le fait sur barkaï micha mal
mais il faut bien le reconnaître en
matière de doctrine est ce que c'est à
notre armée à protéger un certain nombre
de sites sensibles et à faire en quelque
sorte le travail des forces de sécurité
ça pose deux problèmes la doctrine c'est
à dire est ce que vraiment l'armée fait
pour ça et puis surtout des problèmes
d'organisation de nos armées certes la
loi de programmation militaire a permis
de remonter la force
tu es reste opérationnelle qui permet
effectivement de monter d'environ onze
mille hommes alors que nos armées
étaient exempts gay avait du mal
effectivement à s'organiser avec la
déflation qui avait été prévu par roland
des héros dans le cadre de la première
lpm mais encore faut-il se demander
aujourd'hui si nous pouvons à la fois
permettre à des soldats d'être sur le
sol français pour protéger des sites
sensibles et également être projetés sur
des théâtres d'opération à
l'international si vous posez la
question comme celles et ceux qui
s'intéressent un peu au sujet des
militaires pas obligatoirement des
militaires de haut rang mais des
capitaines ou des soldats du rang dont
on en voit certains d'ailleurs qui sont
un peu partout dans paris dans le xvème
en particulier il vous distillera qui
rognent sur leurs vacances c'est pas
terrible mais aussi pour certains ils
rognent sur la préparation qui leur
permet ensuite d'aller se battre sur les
opérations extérieures et ça c'est
beaucoup plus dangereux parce que si on
envoie des troupes qui ne sont pas
préparés à cela
en tout cas qui n'ont pas eu le temps de
se préparer à ça alors il ya un danger
effectivement d'erreurs voire même pour
leur propre vie des des problématiques
d'organisation de notre de nos
opérations extérieures
donc autant encore une fois je crois que
la décision qui a été prise par le
gouvernement après les événements du 11
janvier a été certainement la bonne sur
une période courte d'un mois un mois et
demi mais mon sentiment aujourd'hui
c'est qu'elle ne peut pas perdurer
alors aujourd'hui hollande a décidé de
maintenir ce dispositif
certes un léger on est plus à dix mille
hommes et environ à 7000 avec des
systèmes de protection dynamique c'est à
dire on est plus statique un endroit
mais on tourne sur plusieurs endroits
il a décidé de le maintenir jusqu'en
2017 avait compris le message en gros on
change rien on ne bouge pas jusqu'aux
élections présidentielles je pense qu'il
est de notre devoir à nous républicains
se poser la question du bien fondé de ce
dispositif
peut-être le réorienter vers des forces
de sécurité intérieure ça me paraît être
déjà une bonne idée d'utiliser de
vérifier aussi si la doctrine d'emploi
des idées de nos armées et bien fondée
un exemple aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu
de ya pas eu d'erreur de fait nos
soldats sont des soldats responsables
mais ils ont entre les mains des armes
de guerre qui peuvent faire un mal fou
si effectivement elles sont mal employés
et juridiquement parlant légalement
parlant nos forces armées sur le
territoire français pour protéger des
sites sensibles sont à la limite de
l'exercice
donc pour l'instant tout va bien mais on
peut se retrouver effectivement
abandonnés avec des situations
juridiquement parlant extrêmement
complexe donc il nous faut nous je le
pense tout en maintenant notre confiance
à la fois nos forces de sécurité à nos
forces armées nous poser la question
d'une réorganisation de nos forces de
sécurité et de défense sur le sol
français
dans le cas des effectivement de la
lutte contre le terrorisme et du
maintien d'un niveau de sécurité tels
que les français l'attendent dans la
perspective des élections près de
l'élection présidentielle c'est
indispensable et c'est de notre
responsabilité danger pour nos armes et
pour nos soldats trous dans la raquette
en matière de sécurité
voilà en tout cas les questions et la
réflexion qui doit être posée entre
aujourd'hui et des prochaines échéances
présidentielles et législatives
voilà mon cher frédéric ce que je
souhaiterais vous dire